But, the most fundamental
assumption of Lucas-Kanade, or
at least the one that in some
sense is most problematic yet,
fixable is this idea that we can use
that Taylor series approximation.
So, the idea of that Taylor series
approximation is that we can make
a small ramp estimate that is the first
linear first order linear estimate.
And then as things move a little bit,
that'll tell us how things change.
And, we've gone over one method.
We talked about non-linear
iterative refinements.
So that if it's, if it's still the right
model in terms of the point nearby
is changing, but it's not linear.
Maybe it's quadratic or something.
We use a bunch of linear
successive approximations.
But actually, that's not the problem
that exists mall, most often.
The one that exists most often is that,
actually, pixel motion is not small.
And so, you can't just assume that you
can tell how things have changed by just
doing a very local analysis.
So to solve that,
we have to do something called
coarse-to-fine estimation.
To illustrate what I mean,
here's a, a simple example.
So, here you see on this one,
on the left side,
I have curves that have been
shifted by only a small amount.
So, when I find one point value,
the nearest match is actually
the correct displacement.
So, they actually fit
a little slope through here.
I can do my local estimate, and I'll
eventually find the, the correct match.
But over here,
I've got a different situation.
So, there is one point, the nearest
match will now be this red point.
All right?
So, it basically has just estimated
the change to be that much.
All right?
Where the actual shift of course,
is much, much more.
All right?
And so, the estimated shift is,
is too small.
So, the question is how
would you fix that?
So, let's take a look at
this on a real picture.
So, here's an example
on some real pictures.
So, this is two frames taken out
of the MPEG garden sequence.
And, what you can see is
that I've got one frame, and
then the next frame the tree
moves to the left quite a bit
because the camera has
moved to the right.
And, you can see the tree in the front
is occluding the tree in the back.
Okay, so question.
Do you think that this is a small enough
motion to be able to run Lucas- Kanade?
No, look,
there's a lot more than one pixel or
a small number of pixel motion
with a planar assumption between.
I'm cov, I'm covering entire
trees in the background.
All right?
So, the problem is, you know,
how could we solve this, right?
How could we eliminate this
problem of large pixel motion?
And, I'm going to show
you with a single slide.
You're going to look at it,
you're going to go, aha!
I get it.
Ready?
Now.
>> Aha!
I get it.
>> What do you get?
>> Okay, here's what you got.
In the top left corner is
the original sequence, all right?
And, you can see that the thing is
moving a whole bunch of pixels.
I don't know,
maybe it's moving let's call it Sep.
On the top, right you'll notice
the picture is drawn the same size, but
I've actually reduced
the pixels in half.
So now, it says there's, like,
90 pixels across, right.
Before, there was something like 180.
Well, gee,
if I was moving seven pixels before,
now I'd only be moving three and
a half pixels.
Do it again.
Now, I've only got 45ish pixels.
Bottom left hand corner.
Now instead of moving three and a half
half of three and a half is one, one and
three quarters.
Okay?
That's still more than one, isn't it?
Yes.
Okay.
Well, cut it in half again.
So now,
I have this picture on the bottom right.
And if you look at that animation,
you'll see,
you can sort of see it
shifting within the pixels.
It's actually less than
a one pixel motion.
Okay?
It's a very blurry picture, and
I had to make it really, blow it up, and
now you can actually see
each pixel in there.
But, you can see that the motion
is a sub-pixel motion.
So basically, what we want to
do is we want to implement
a motion recovery method that
takes this coarse image.
And then iteratively, or
I should say multi-scalewise,
goes to a finer and finer image.